Hallo, da bin ich wieder, Anita aus
dem Oldenburger Münsterland.
Die Landwirtin ist genervt vom
schlechten Image der Bauern.
Deshalb dreht Anita Lucassen Videos
in ihrem Kuhstall.
Ihre Mission: ein positives Bild
schaffen von Landwirten wie sie.
Was mich am meisten stört, ist,
dass die Landwirte pauschal an
den Pranger gestellt werden,
dass durch negative Beispiele
wir Landwirte skandalisiert
und als Umweltverschmutzer und
Tierquäler dargestellt werden.
Die Videos veröffentlicht sie auf
der Internetplattform MyKuhTube.
Alle sollen sehen, dass es
ihren Tieren gut geht.
Das muss ohne großes
Werbebudget gehen.
Hallo, da bin ich wieder, Anita aus
dem Oldenburger Münsterland.
Heute möchte ich euch zeigen, wie
der Ablauf beim Melken ist.
Dass die Kühe zurzeit ein
wenig zappelig sind, liegt daran,
dass die Fliegen sie im Moment
immer wieder zwicken.
Ihr Mann Michael Lucassen übernimmt
ihre Arbeit, wenn sie dreht.
Na ja, unser Problem ist, glaub ich,
wir sind ‘ne schwindende Gesellschaft,
die Landwirtschaft an sich. Wir
werden immer weniger Betriebe.
Und die Bevölkerung entfernt sich
immer mehr von der Landwirtschaft.
Dadurch, dass [wir] immer
weniger werden
und in den Dörfern auch immer
weniger Betriebe existieren,
wird es immer schwieriger, den
Verbrauchern das nahezubringen.
Die 39-Jährige ist auf einem Bauernhof
mit Milchkühen groß geworden.
Seit mehr als zehn Jahren
führt sie zusammen
mit ihrem Ehemann ihren
eigenen Betrieb.
Sie hat 320 Tiere. Dafür braucht sie
105 Hektar Land.
Viele Flächen sind hinzugepachtet. Das
kostet im Jahr mindestens 40.000 Euro.
Die Tiere stehen das
ganze Jahr im Stall
und bekommen eine spezielle Fütterung
aus Mais gemischt mit Kraftfutter.
Kritiker nennen das Massentierhaltung.
Ja, wir sind hier in einer Region,
wo sehr hohe Pachtpreise sind,
und wir haben hier eine
intensiv geführte Herde,
die eine Milchleistung von etwa
11.000 Liter pro Jahr hat.
Der deutsche Durchschnitt
liegt bei etwa 8.500 Liter pro Jahr –
um das mal in Relation zu setzen –,
und wir könnten halt eben
diese Pachtpreise nicht erwirtschaften,
wenn wir nicht diese hohe
Milchleistung hätten.
11.000 Liter pro Jahr, pro Kuh.
Tierschützer fordern: mehr Weidehaltung!
Doch nur ein kleiner Teil der
Herde ist draußen.
Für die Hochleistungskühe ist
das Gras viel zu mager.
Sie sehen sich nicht als ein
Teil der Agrarindustrie,
sondern als ein Familienunternehmen,
mit einem Angestellten und einem Lehrling.
Monatelang waren die Milchpreise im
Keller, oft unter 30 Cent pro Liter.
Wie soll ein Unternehmen da
wirtschaftlich sein, fragen sie?
Bei ihrer Familie bleibt wenig hängen,
manchmal unter 2000 Euro im Monat.
Heute bin ich hier mit euch bei den
Kälberhütten und möchte euch zeigen,
wie die Kälber eigentlich aus
dem Nuckel-Eimer saufen.
Hier haben wir ein Kälbchen, das
schon fleißig am Trinken ist.
Ihre Videos zeigen: Mit Romantik hat
die moderne Tierzucht wenig zu tun.
Anita Lucassen befruchtet zum
Beispiel ihre Kühe künstlich.
Herdenmanagement: für jede
Kuh einen passenden Bullen.
Das Erbgut von 25 männlichen
Vererbern kauft sie ein.
Diese Kühe bekommen bald Kälber. Ziel
ihrer Zucht sind gesunde Hochleistungskühe,
die viel Milch geben und möglichst
ohne Hörner geboren werden.
Für Naturschützer ein Bruch der Ethik.
Die Landwirtin denkt da praktisch,
denn die Hörner einer Kuh
können gefährlich sein.
Und man steht gerade daneben und
hat dann das spitze Horn im Brustkorb –
das ist mindestens ‘n blauer Fleck,
wenn nicht ‘ne sehr heftige Prellung
bis hin halt zu tödlichen Verletzungen,
die dadurch passieren können.
Die Videos der Landwirtin sind im Internet
schon über eine Million Mal angeklickt.
Das zeigt, die Menschen interessieren
sich dafür, woher ihr Essen kommt.